well sometimes truth really is Stranger
Than Fiction this is going to be hard
for many of you to believe but the
transformation of Alan dershowitz seems
almost complete he is now representing
my pillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell
now when I say transformation in the
interview we're going to look at shortly
dershowitz says he's still a liberal
Democrat who voted for Biden but that
he's getting involved in these cases
because of the principles the legal
principles Etc
it is a cartoonish mess
that pillow is
and then you add dershowitz to it and it
is just some kind of very strange uh uh
salad of some kind I don't even know
what words to apply to it here is
dershowitz saying he is going to ask for
a special Master for the pillow cell
phone it's every single one of these
things couldn't be a bigger joke
remember that Mike pillow's phone was
seized by the FBI at a Hardy's
drive-through not long ago and here is
pillow interviewing his new lawyer Alan
dershowitz issue The subpoena for the
telephone so that they could get in
search the telephone completely and what
we're seeking is what the president
Trump got in the Mar-A-Lago case the
appointment of a special investigator to
look into this or return of the cell
phone because the the search was a
general search the kind of General
search that the framers of our
constitution
um wanted to specifically Outlaw in the
Fourth Amendment now dershowitz is a
lawyer and so are Trump's lawyers Alina
Haba and Christina Bob and all those
people they made the same argument after
the search warrant was executed at
Mar-A-Lago they said this was a fishing
Expedition it was General they sort of
took everything there was no discretion
this is unconstitutional and then of
course it didn't actually turn out that
any judge or Court agreed with them here
is an interview on the law and crime
Network wherein Alan dershowitz explains
why are you working for Mike pillow
now the answer might be because Mike
pillow has a lot of money that might be
the real answer I don't know but take a
listen to some of this well thank you
first of all let me tell you why I'm
representing Mike Lindell I agree with
him about very little I think the
election was fair I think he's wrong in
challenging uh the election we're on
completely different sides I'm a liberal
Democrat I voted for Biden he's a
Conservative Republican I think it's as
critically important for people on my
side of the political fence people who
are Biden supporters supporters of the
election to hold the justice department
accountable for trying to Target our
political enemies I think the criticism
should come from within our party not
only outside the party so I'm very
anxious to defend the constitution on
behalf of Michael Lindell the search
itself was clearly a general search okay
and then he makes the same point we
heard him make in the earlier segment
now listen here's the story with this
if
how can I say this
the fact that it took this long
for there to be any action given Trump's
consistent wrongdoing year after year
after year tells us that if there were
really
any
biased interest
in how this went down
it's that the FBI and doj were too
reluctant to get involved in going after
Trump
so what pillow and Trump and dershowitz
want us to believe is the fact that
these things happened at all that there
was the raid on Mar-A-Lago that there
was the seizure of pillow's cell phone
the fact that these things happened at
all is indicative of political bias and
attempts at political retribution
there has been so much wrong doing that
the way I see it is the fact that it
took this long suggests they were really
reluctant and they wanted to be really
careful and really sure and of course
all the evidence we have points that way
when you look at
the search warrant for the uh for the
Mar-A-Lago when you look at the fact
that the Attorney General signed off the
FBI director signed off a judge signed
off everything was made just so
and it didn't really matter to the Trump
is because they still said it was
illegal it's a political Witch Hunt all
these different things they'll say that
either way
but so far no court has found that any
of those arguments have Merit my
expectation
is that courts will similarly find that
dershowitz's arguments about the pillow
phone seizure
pillow phone seizure those are the terms
we're using we'll also be without Merit
that's my expectation we will watch and
we will see the continued bad news for
the failed former president Donald Trump
in an appeals court now says the
Department of Justice can resume its
criminal probe of the classified
documents that were obtained at
Mar-A-Lago remember once that search
warrant was executed and the documents
were taken
um seized the Trump side said we need a
special Master there's medical documents
in there uh there's privileged documents
in there special Masters got to look at
all of it and you know classify
Declassified just a complete and total
mess
we are now moving beyond that as CNN
reports a federal appeals court is
allowing the justice department to
continue looking at those documents
marked classified seized from Trump
the emergency intervention upends a
trial judge's order over those documents
that had blocked Federal investigators
work on the documents and is a strong
rebuke of the Trump team's attempt to
suggest without evidence that materials
Were Somehow Declassified remember what
happened
the special Master said listen
if you're gonna make this argument about
classification then make it and we're
going to move on very quickly if you
don't because the special Master said
which I told you uh two days ago
you give me a document that says top
secret
and you don't present any evidence that
it was Declassified that's it
essentially a cut the crap moment and
that is exactly what is going on here
the ruling was issued by a three-judge
panel of the 11th U.S Circuit of uh
Court of Appeals
two of the three judges were nominated
by Donald Trump this is supposed to be
quite a conservative court and it really
goes to show that the arguments Trump
was making in public were completely and
totally absurd
um perhaps the funniest line from the
entire thing
is quote for our part we cannot discern
why the plaintiff would have an
individual interest in or need for any
of the 100 documents with classification
markings and that sort of says it all we
can't figure that out as well it was for
Trump's Memoirs he doesn't read or write
Trump wanted to review the documents he
doesn't read or write they were for
Trump's Library the library is not even
something Trump is really thinking of
according to many insiders there's just
no reasonable explanation other than bad
ones he wanted to sell them he wanted to
use them as leverage horrible horrible
things that border on treason the judges
couldn't understand it either so the
investigation continues there is now an
indictment watch taking place we'll see
where we are another month or two from
now let's look at
um here's a question that we've been
asking for a while
and that question is
are all of these investigations into
Trump going to hurt his approval rating
and on the one hand
if approval
reacted to the real world the answer
would be it sure as hell should look at
all of the legal trouble and wrongdoing
that we've learned about just in the
last six weeks about Donald Trump but
when you're dealing with a cult it
doesn't always work that way
and indeed Trump's support Remains
unmoved by investigations poll finds
this is in the New York Times is the
upshot and it says even during Peak
crises during his presidency views of
him were static post-presidency polls
have continued the trend
the American public's view of trump
is remarkably stable across a number of
different measures in recent months even
as he faces multiple investigations and
remains a central figure in the midterm
elections this is a New York Times Siena
College poll and it finds 44 percent of
Voters view Trump favorably 53 percent
view him unfavorably the recent poll was
fielded early this month after news of
the Justice Department's inquiry into
Trump's handling of confidential
documents but before yesterday the day
before yesterday's lawsuit announcement
the level of trump support has
effectively been unchanged since the
last poll in July which was during the
January 6th committee hearings this is
occult folks and that is what we should
expect and think about it uh Jim Jones
people's Temple
this is the you know drink the Kool-Aid
disaster that we now uh know about
uh and that we've known about for
decades I should say it's not it's not
recent news if you went to the followers
of Jim Jones and you said he's under
investigation for sexual assault and
he's under investigation for
embezzlement and he's under
investigation for tax evasion and we
have pretty good evidence on all of it
do you think that Jim Jones followers
would have said oh well then I'm no I'm
not behind him anymore no because it was
a cult and that is how cult leaders work
when you don't care about reality to
start your support of trump
reality isn't going to dissuade you from
your support of trump and when he said I
could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
I wouldn't lose support he wasn't wrong
that's exactly right and if he did shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue we all know how
it would go it would be well he was
provoked it was self-defense there was a
violent antifa or BLM member who was
doing something to Trump that's how it
would go it wouldn't necessarily be
it's great that he shot someone although
he probably would be able to find that
uh you'd probably find some people who
say that the person he shot was one of
those pedophiles that Q Anon is fighting
against or whatever but for the most
part people go no no it was self-defense
you got to understand the circumstances
and he's there's threats to his life all
the time he reasonably feared for it and
all
he's absolutely right when he said I
would be able to shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue and not lose any support so it
shouldn't surprise us that Trump's
approval hasn't diminished at all but it
raises questions about what happens with
trumpism in 2022 and in 2024 which will
be something we look at extensively in
the next few weeks leading up to these
midterm elections which are now imminent
we're now looking at looking at what is
it five and a half six weeks or so from
now make sure that you're following me
on Twitter at dpacman and let me know
what you think is there anything at this
point that could erode Trump's support
among the core supporters that are
mostly everything that he has left or
all that he has left better said
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course a
community funded program we depend on
the gracious and generous support of so
many in our audience you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you will get access to
the bonus show you will get access to
the Daily Commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show you will be
invited to the members only town halls
and have Priority Access to the uh
regular town halls there are so many
great benefits that you can take
advantage of by signing up at
joinpakman.com let's hear from the most
important people
in the audience and those are the
viewers and the listeners we'll take
some calls now from our Discord at
davidpackman.com
Discord starting with I hope I
pronounced this correctly Rahman from
Minneapolis welcome did I did I
pronounce that okay
yes you did David how are you doing I'm
doing well
good a long time viewer been watching
your show since high school wow thank
you
my question is um with everything that's
been going on the last two years do you
believe the Republican party is trying
to reinstitute a 21st century version of
Jim Crow
well most of them don't even know what
that is so I would say not conscious I
don't think they're using Jim Crow as a
model
but I do think that they are reacting
with a lot of the same instincts where
as they're increasingly frustrated that
the law doesn't allow them to do certain
things they want to do they're trying to
find ways around it to achieve
essentially the same outcomes if that
makes sense and that includes when it
comes to immigration policy this
includes with when it comes to
educational policy and you know this
idea of get rid of the Department of
Education different things like that the
impact of a lot of those things would be
similar to the impact of of uh some of
the things in place during the Jim Crow
era so in that sense I would say yeah to
some degree
yeah because when you see when you look
at back in the history books and you you
could see the parallels uh with with
people going against the LGBT community
going with the voter restriction yep the
anti-abortion laws when you look at
Illinois what happened with Mary Miller
and she she was ABS she was saying this
is a victory for white life yeah that's
the the that was quoted language
I agree with you 100 100 and really all
we can do is try to ensure that the
people who want to do this stuff don't
get into positions of power sadly many
of them are already in positions of
power but at every opportunity to vote
let's try to prevent more of them from
being voted in
okay that was my only question thank you
for taking my call David all right thank
you Rockman from Minneapolis very much
appreciate the call let's go next to
Lucas from Massachusetts Lucas welcome
to the show what's on your mind today
hey David hi Hayden I'm ecstatic right
now because I didn't get to um ask my
question last week but here's my
question please
so a lot of people are optimistic about
the war in Ukraine because of
ukrainian's advances I'm not and here's
why okay
I think that I worry that if the GOP
takes back Congress it will block
Ukraine funding and decide with Putin
what do you think I think they almost
certainly will now just as a heads up
you've got Discord notifications
blinging in the background and that is a
faux pas during the phone call okay so
if you can get those turned off that
would be really great I think you were
absolutely correct and when the if
Republicans get the opportunity to stop
the funding to Ukraine
they will do it
um under the guise of we have to take
care of America first that's what
they're saying and of course many people
will look at it and say this is another
way that you're playing soft with Putin
and they'll say it's not about playing
soft with Putin it's about we need to
deal with crime and immigration and all
these different things and of course we
can walk and chew gum at the same time
but yeah they will they will try to at
least cut funding to Ukraine and that's
the type of explanation that they'll
give all right thank you for ask
answering my question I've heard a lot
of different perspectives on it I'm glad
to hear yours all right Lucas thank you
very much
welcome all right there we go
um okay let's go next to Alan from Miami
Florida Alan welcome
Alan you were on the air but it looks
like you have the wrong microphone
selected welcome to the program you can
speak if you can get configured
correctly
and last chance for Alan from Miami
Florida who is in tech hell as we might
call it welcome Allen hello can you hear
me now I can hear you
how are you David I'm doing well
good good
um so I had a question about EVS I find
EVS very interesting I know you've
talked about them
um in the past on several occasions so
um now as you probably know the biggest
issue with EVS from a from a cost
standpoint is the the most expensive
part right which is the battery and more
specifically the materials you sourced
and used to manufacture these batteries
yes right and if you look at the
trajectory of EV prices or EV Vehicles
their prices
um they have been going down
but
um the price of these
of these batteries are still a big
impediment right yes so what do you
think maybe the government can do what
kind of role do you think or a positive
role
um do you think the government can play
um in trying to resolve this issue or
helping to resolve this issue the reason
I ask is because you know a lot of
people in EV space will say that the the
biggest impediment for the middle class
or let's say just regular folk being
able to afford an EV
um is decision basically is is the cost
of the materials to manufacture the
batteries so there's a couple different
things here first of all in terms of
what the government can do that's not
the most interesting question to me
because like the government can do what
it's done in other industries that it
wants to support rebates subsidies
preferential tax treatment the
government has its tools that it can use
and I'm fine with the government doing
that I think the problem you're pointing
out is going to resolve itself with more
electric vehicle uh demand and as as
adoption increases I mean listen it's
like when you look at
um uh computer processors right and you
look at I remember when we got from
Radio Shack this 100 megahertz Pentium
computer and it was like twenty five
hundred dollars in whatever year that
was which is like a lot more money now
you know it's probably five or six grand
now and now you get you know
multi-gigahertz processors for way less
buy some of the same
um laws that govern the reduced price of
hard drive storage and the reduced cost
of processing power I think you're going
to see absolutely the same thing with
with electric vehicle batteries
um the other thing is
communicating to people that because
electric vehicles are so much more
efficient than internal combustion
engines on a per mile basis it's also
possible that while The Upfront cost of
an electric vehicle can be higher are
the although those costs are also coming
down the long-term cost because the
electricity is cheaper than the gas and
the efficiency is higher so your cost
per mile is lower the total cost of
ownership is is going to be less so I
think it's a matter of we've got to
communicate that that's already the case
the prices will continue to come down
battery recycling and reuse is going to
be developed all of these things are
these are really engineering problems
that are that are like what we saw in
Computing and in other spaces it's all
going to get resolved is my view
okay I see well it seems to me that that
as far as you mentioned uh recycling
that's a huge thing that many companies
are trying to to push is to try to get
um these batteries to kind of get back
into the the life cycle because you
still have valuable uh use but it seems
and it could be wrong here maybe you can
correct me on this but it seems like I
don't know if the government or federal
government has any sort of program to
recycle or a sense of ice recycling of
these things because that I don't know
but they may they may or they may not
yeah so that that could be an area maybe
that that sort of The Government Can can
uh can address because so far right now
it seems like it's just startups that
are coming out of nowhere that are
trying to resolve that issue and the
government isn't doing much I would like
the government uh to more uh
incentivizing this uh technology
development but it's happening Alan it's
all happening oh thank you well that's
it thank you appreciate it Alan from
Miami Florida quite a scene down there
that I can tell you for sure let's go oh
just a reminder for everybody waiting in
Discord to chat with me if your nickname
is anything other than a name and a
location uh whether it's nicknames or
single words or whatever the case may be
uh jokes you're not going to get called
on which is fine if you're just
listening but just so you know why you
won't be getting called on let's go next
to moshev from Toronto Canada welcome
hello David hello
hello
um so I was wondering I don't know how
how invested you are in uh Canadian
politics but I was wondering if I could
get your opinion on how well you think
uh Justin Trudeau has been doing over
the last while and and your opinion
about the uh the uh the new uh
conservative party lever conservative
party leader Pierre paliav who just won
the
um who just won the race for a
conservative party leader you know I
think it wouldn't be appropriate for me
to comment not because I think it's
inappropriate to comment on foreign
leaders but because there are just so
many people who follow it much more
closely than I do that I couldn't
possibly give you a very informed take I
will say I recently when I was in
Montreal uh met with and chatted with um
MP Anthony House Father who likes what
Trudeau is doing but they're in the same
party right so he may have a dog in that
fight so to speak
um but no I don't I don't I don't think
I'm informed enough to really be saying
Hey listen to my opinion about Canadian
politics
yeah well they they the MPS will always
vote for the people in their party no
matter what pretty much that's pretty
much how it works well tell me I mean
how do you think things are day to day
in Toronto
well yeah I mean yeah we're dealing with
uh the cost of living being in a in a
pretty terrible place right now
um
um the government's working on getting
them to play in place which which is
interesting the question I guess the
question I wonder what you would think
is is uh if now is the right time to
start implementing like these these uh
high-cost uh programs
um at this point where everyone's trying
to like save money produce inflation you
know you set a Dental Care Program yeah
yeah they want to start they want to
start doing a federal program or you get
coverage from the government for uh for
dental care because up until now it's
it's complete that's completely been uh
private and only only paid for by
private insurance well listen again
without commenting specifically about
what's going on in Canada there are
always people who will say this is the
wrong time to do anything that involves
spending money but my view tends to be
when it comes to things like Health Care
why would you wait people the the sooner
people get care the better off we are
uh-huh even if that means risking
um the um like the money being like that
money being spent elsewhere well you'd
have to then say well what else do you
want to spend it on and compare
oh I would say not spend not spend it at
all
uh as a uh as of this current moment
yeah okay all right well I'd like to see
the numbers on it but again I'm not the
best position to comment on that
okay all right thank you for your time
all right thanks motion from Toronto
great to hear from you let's go uh let's
go next to Brandon from North Carolina
Brandon welcome to the program
Brandon from North Carolina you are
muting yourself right now it's a self
mute as soon as you unmute yourself
you'll be able to hear me yes I can
hello David nice to talk to you likewise
let's go Brandon uh so uh yeah I just
was wanting to ask you uh well Brandon
Brandon wait a second you're you're shot
out of a cannon can you move the
microphone a little bit further from
your mouth
of course sorry
that's better that's smoother I like
that okay is that okay so you can hear
me better yeah much better okay uh so uh
yeah I was wanting to ask you so what's
your sit uh mind uh think about
um the whole Alvin brag not wanting to
prosecute
Trump on uh his finances I have not read
much about that is Alvin Bragg was that
the New York D.A that it led to two
investigators quitting because they were
like this is going nowhere our work is
pointless yeah uh uh he's the southern
district ah I see it here yeah listen at
the time when that was that was news
it seemed to me that it was obvious that
that was going on to some degree we've
been saying for a while it seems that
nobody wants to be the first to
prosecute Trump and we'll see if federal
charges end up being the first thing
here's my view on it if the facts say
that a prosecution is correct not
Prosecuting is a cop-out and it's
cowardly now that being said that being
said
we only want to bring charges against
anyone random people or a former
president when the evidence supports it
so it's not prosecute Trump because I
think Trump's a terrible president it's
if that's what the evidence says should
be done it should be done and not doing
it is a real problem
yeah absolutely
all right how are things otherwise in
North Carolina uh uh pretty good other
than uh
besides our words and infrastructure and
stuff pretty good but um other than that
um pretty good uh Beasley's ahead and
also as long as we don't elect blood
what's wrong with the roads is it like
potholes or what yeah potholes like I'll
which roads are pretty much just like
crumbling you can literally just see the
wear on them like it's just you can just
see the the wear and tear on them it's
pretty bad that's horrible that's
horrible all right Brandon well thank
you for the call thank you very much
take it easy David YouTube there's
Brandon from North Carolina let's take a
quick break and get right back to the
callers if you're holding on to talk to
me hold on just a moment longer because
we're going right back to the phones
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's
speak to a few more people we take calls
via Discord on Fridays at
davidpackman.com
Discord that's the place to do it let's
go to Harry from Columbus Ohio Harry
what's going on there
hey can you hear me well I can hear you
let's put it that way
okay I'll be very brief and I'm very
excited for your new Finance Channel I
saw you dropped your first video
yesterday we now have multiple multiple
videos on the finance channel the
audience is responding sort of mildly
positively which I think is as good as
you can hope for on the internet you
know
yeah I agree so I'll be real quick okay
now I know very very little about you
know buying a house securing my assets
anything like that yep with the recent
raises in interest rates from the FED
does it make any sense to buy a house
until those come down like I have no
idea what calculations I need to make
before well here's the general thing
yeah that's it thank you so much here's
the general thing okay as a general rule
and we have a clip coming out on the
finance Channel about this when interest
rates go up
home prices come down they tend to move
in opposite directions now it's not
always literally true sometimes interest
rates going up might just mean home
prices are steady instead of going down
but the idea is interest rates and
prices move in opposite directions and I
explain why in a clip on the finance
Channel which will be out very soon so
if you were in a position
to buy a home cash
High interest rate environments can be
good moments to do that now of course if
you're selling and buying often you're
you're subject to the same the same
market conditions that make buying
attractive might make you have to sell
your house for Less so it really depends
on the market and your personal
situation and whether you're only
looking to buy or buying and selling but
the principle at play is in general
interest rates up houses down
yeah it seems like I'm gonna have to
make a pretty you know big Financial
story a pretty big mortgage change to
get into uh a house so it doesn't seem
like it's gonna be the right time for me
if you have a mortgage at two and a half
percent right now and in the new place
you would need a mortgage at five
percent it may not be the right time for
you that's perfectly reasonable
okay thank you for the call very much
appreciate it mortgage rates complicated
stuff complicated stuff which we
absolutely will be dealing with on the
finance Channel let's go to rob from
Massachusetts Rob welcome to the show
all right thank you uh first time on I
have a really quick question sure I have
a right-wing friend at work and he tends
to
like comment on on YouTube things I post
and the thing is I've learned to think
like he does so there's like a little
version of him in my head
um like trying to be a right in person
and I wonder if that happens to you if
you find it useful for arguments or if
it's just like frustrating because you
know that like they might better
themselves in the movie no that's real
it's really good and it's useful and and
I would argue that it's actually quite
healthy which is okay we see a headline
uh gas prices down two months in a row I
think it's great to say okay
how are how are Republicans going to
react to this do they have a point if so
should I modify my view if not why is it
that they're actually wrong I mean maybe
gas prices is a bad example but I think
that that's actually very healthy it's
it's arguably a version of Steel Manning
which is rather than straw Manning your
political opponents you Steel Man and
say what's the best case I can make for
their View and if I still think it's a
bad case it reinforces that I've come to
the right conclusion I think that's very
healthy as long as it doesn't become
like intrusive or pathological
oh great yeah listen to Sam Anderson
with steel Manning so that's I never
thought of it thank you all right Rob
thank you very much that that last bit
was a little garbled I didn't understand
that but I did understand thank you and
I really do appreciate that we're taking
calls via Discord just as a reminder to
everybody waiting to chat with me if you
actually want the opportunity to talk
your nickname in the waiting Lobby on
Discord needs to be your name and where
you're calling from or where you're
calling from and your name a lot of
people with nicknames are not going to
get called on okay just as just as a
heads up so everybody understands that
let's go next to Tristan from Boston
Tristan welcome
hey David what's up how are you
I'm feeling okay good so
um
my question would be you remember a
while back the uh
detective work by
that American mucker Acres pack is what
I ended up getting uh Madison cawthorne
fired
uh well you think yeah I mean I don't
know that cawthorne lost only because of
the salacious stuff released about him I
don't know but I remember the I remember
the American muckrakers pack and the
stuff that they released certainly yes
do you think we'll hear from them again
in actually succeeding in smearing
someone enough to get them out of
Congress so I don't remember if it was
the same people who tried with Lauren
bobert and it didn't go anywhere because
it wasn't very well sourced or if that
was a different organization I just
don't remember offhand but it's sort of
a question about a prediction I have no
idea I don't know if they have dirt on
someone else but it's certainly
conceivable that we would
the site fire bobert is still up and I
assume it will be up
for as long as it takes for her to
leave Congress
all right well we will keep an eye on it
other than that the
their site right now is just a bunch of
criminal Republicans not looking so
caught in uh not so hot poses
fair so I guess that's what the best we
can hope for for now
all right Tristan very good we'll keep
an eye on it
cool thanks all right Tristan from
Boston with a very important declaration
let's go next to Philip from Germany
Philip welcome
hello hello uh can you hear me well so I
can hear you there is a static hiss in
the background whenever you talk
okay I don't really know why but my main
question is that basically back in the
times of the Civil War the rules of the
Democratic and Republican party were
kind of reversed where the Democrats
were the one with with the slaves and
Abraham Lincoln was from the Republicans
we're freeing the slaves and so on and
nowadays well it's all kind in Reverse
especially when you have Confederate
flags being waived at January 6 and all
that and you have an idea how that
reversal came to be yeah there's
actually been multiple reversals and I
think that you know this can be very
confusing even to Americans so my advice
on this issue is to think about it in
the following way
the right wing
was in favor of owning slaves and the
party name that was the a correct name
at the time is less relevant than the
fact that it was the political right
that wanted the slaves and the political
quite frankly Center and left and even
to some degree center right that did not
and that makes it so you don't have to
remember when the party realignments
took place
okay but still kind of weird that the
Republicans were Center or or perhaps
even Center left not sure well remember
not all Republicans Republican not all
of Lincoln's Republicans wanted to end
slavery that's that's Lincoln did but
not the entire Republican party did not
want to
also interesting I guess but yeah it
kind of happens to go that way that
basically the Democrats were were
hardlined into slaves and yeah Lincoln's
Direction was yeah against this yeah I
would even want to double check that
because I don't even know for sure that
that it's that Democrats were into
slaves let me double check because there
were multiple parties at the time but
I'm gonna let you go because that
hissing is just so bad okay
oh sorry okay no problem no problem all
right good we'll get that figured out
for next time but that is that is quite
an audio element that was taking place
there let's go next to Alex from
California Alex welcome
hey David can you hear me yes I can
hey David so um have you covered the 60
second 60 Minute interview from Joe
Biden and about Taiwan I covered the
interview in terms of Biden saying that
the pandemic is over I did not cover the
Taiwan piece I was so busy early in the
week that I didn't even watch the entire
interview I just did a story on the the
coveted part
okay so
um I'm curious because every time Joe
Biden says something about Taiwan like
if China invades we're going to send
troops but every time that happens it
always seems that the White House always
backs pedals and say oh we don't know
about that or oh uh we don't stand by
that um what do you think about that I
think it's typical posturing it's you
you you you say something the President
says something a little hawkish and then
we're when there's a request for a
clarification you sort of walk back a
little bit and say it's not our intent
or it's not what was meant I think that
that it that is completely standard
political posturing to sort of keep
those that you consider your adversaries
a little bit unbalanced where it's not
totally clear exactly what they're
willing to do it's like a minor version
of when Putin talks about launching
nukes
um I I think it's just typical posturing
well it's politics
all right so um if let's say somehow or
for some reason China does invade Taiwan
yes do you do you believe that America
should step in with their like not just
like what sending funding to Taiwan but
like sending troops like American troops
too like how about Taiwan I am not ready
at this point in time to say that the
U.S should get involved militarily in
defense of Taiwan against China I
believe that China would be wrong to
invade Taiwan of course but I am very
careful about declaring support for
American Military interventions so right
now I can't tell you that I would
support that I would have to study the
issue more
that's fair but like I feel like if you
know China does invade Taiwan uh I feel
like that would set like a bad president
if America doesn't do something because
like you can't Ukraine is doing well
because we're sending a bunch of AIDS um
to their way but uh in the case of like
China and Taiwan I feel like this is
like a really different situation yeah
the scale is completely different and
the circumstances are completely
different listen I agree I think that
military action would ideally happen in
Coalition and
um I am not at this point ready to say
uh that I would say yes the U.S needs to
get in there
um one final thing
um do you believe that
um people or people are comparing like
the China Taiwan situation to Russian
Ukraine and saying how
um how Russian is doing poorly and how
things are not going in Russia's favor
during the war and people believe that
that might reflect or might be this
situation if China invades Taiwan
because I think that that it is a
totally different situation I do not
think it is logical to extrapolate from
how Ukraine is doing uh how Taiwan would
do I I don't think that that would be a
fair
um assess a fair assumption
okay
um that's all David day for thank you
for taking my call all right thank you
Alex from California very very important
declaration let's go to Grant from Iowa
City Iowa Grant welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
uh hey David
um I saw your interview with uh Ben
Dixon yesterday it was really
interesting thank you um yeah it's clear
that uh the Christian Nationals movement
is definitely growing or at least
becoming more bold yes
um and so I was just wondering I know I
don't know if you identify as like
agnostic or atheist I'm not sure but so
I don't know how much um interaction
like personally you've had with
Evangelical conservative Christians do
you think
um not the politicians like just like
General people in public
um do you think they're motivated more
by
um a desire for power or are they
motivated more by fear
um personally in my experience I kind of
grew up in that kind of you know realm
and uh I think there's a there's a great
fear they have uh he's like afraid of
like God punishing them
my most extensive interactions with
American evangelicals was when I went to
Indiana because my girlfriend has family
there and the my my girlfriend's Jewish
but is she has a part of her family
that's Evangelical Christians and what I
saw in speaking to them a lot of fear
and a lot of fear-driven conspiratorial
beliefs
and it did not feel to me like now I'm
not talking about politicians I'm
talking about random people which was
your question it did not feel like a
thirst for power was there Guiding Light
it genuinely seemed like it was fear
yeah yeah that's just interesting to me
because I think um
just in my own experience like when I
went to college and stuff and just had
you know classes where we were looking
at other uh just groups in the world I
was like oh
um this is not that scary and uh right
there's nothing to be afraid of and and
like
I don't know even just like I'm still a
Christian but like
um my view of like God has changed so
much from what it used to be there's
like this this angry God he wanted to
punish us anytime he could
um so I don't know I kind of think I've
enjoyed talking with more conservative
Christians and evangelicals um over the
last few years because I kind of like
uh just get to know how they're feeling
about stuff and offer different
perspectives and for some of them it
seems like oh okay um they start to
learn
like
it's it's not as you know horrifying as
as it might be I guess to um yeah that's
really interesting to hear and that you
came to that conclusion because one of
the things that I've thought about is
you know I guess I guess I consider
myself agnostic although whenever I
explain My Views people will write in
and they'll say David you're actually an
atheist whatever call me whatever you
want but my view is uh I think it's
completely possible that some kind of
God or higher power exists I've just not
seen any evidence of it but one of the
things that I've come to believe is
contrary to much of this fire and
brimstone stuff from the Evangelical
side if there were such a higher power
it seems to me that if God created such
complicated uh human beings God would
not be this black white vindictive
um uh Arbiter that some Christianity
makes him out to be and uh it sounds
sort of like you've come to the same
idea
oh yeah absolutely absolutely so
um well I can let you get some other
people now all right but I just thank
you so much I appreciate the call yeah
thanks for taking my call and in fact
what Grant from Iowa is letting me do is
just end the segment because we are at
the end of our time today I always am
just so broken up that I cannot get to
everyone who's waiting to talk to me
but that means that hopefully next week
some people will call in so I will speak
to you then we'll take a quick break and
be back with more right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get to the Friday
mailbag where you can write to me and
sometimes it'll appear on the show you
can email info davidpackman.com ideally
with a substantive commentary but
sometimes there is very little substance
and that's okay I want to start today
with an email from a right winger I
think
who thinks they're on to me they think
they know my trick take a look at this
message Andrew wrote to me and said it's
a nice trick
good afternoon sir
I noticed that you only discussed the
dumbest or the dumb Republicans on your
show it's a nice trick it's the same
trick Tucker and Sean Hannity and Don
Lemon and many others use you will find
no shortage of idiots on both sides of
the island what you do is shine a light
on just those people
do you ever plan on having a
conversation with anyone that you can't
tip the outcome in your favor if your
arguments are so good you should be able
to talk to anyone not just the pillow
guy and Jesse Lee Peterson or whatever
his name is I read the comments your
audience writes and I must say that the
most ignorant that they the most
ignorant and misinworn people in America
and what's scary is that these people
think they are the Smart Ones I don't
even do this for a living and I can pick
apart every single one of your arguments
or at least show where you are being a
hypocrite I honestly used to really like
you I know
I like to hear solid arguments from both
sides but now I realize you are just a
fraud I might as well call you Hannity
Jr it's the same Playbook bro you know
we've so first of all they never tell
you who the smart conservatives are
tell me exactly who they are because I
go well Ben Shapiro
I interviewed Ben Shapiro on the show
it didn't go great for him it wasn't
like terribly humiliating but he didn't
make a lot of sense
and then he's refused all subsequent
invitations
I've had Michael Knowles on the show
some of these right Wingers go Knowles
is the smart one
to the extent that Jordan Peterson is a
right-winger people say well but
Peterson's been on and he has an open
invitation we tried to get him back on
recently uh we had Andrew Sullivan on
he's a right winger and I find him to be
intelligent and then no those aren't the
right smart right-wingers or they're
they're not really right-wingers or
whatever we we interview all sorts of
people okay all sorts of people this is
a very boring criticism
let's go next to Earl now I'm going to
be totally honest with you
I don't know if this email from Earl is
satire
Earl wrote in about raising the minimum
wage and said I am so disappointed to
see encouragement from your people to
raise the minimum wage to 15 an hour
this could destroy capitalism as we know
it forcing millions of businesses and
CEOs out of work because people are too
lazy to work and too stupid to budget I
am not an economist like Thomas Sowell
but I can do simple math so let's start
725 an hour is 290 a week that's fifteen
thousand eighty dollars for the year
average health insurance is only 150 a
week that's 600 a month average
apartment rent for a one bedroom is only
275 a week that's 1100 a month average
food costs for one person is only 51 a
week average Transportation 65 a week
utility bills 35 a week
so to survive we don't need a 15 per
hour minimum wage all the person has to
do is work two full-time jobs and drive
Uber in their spare time I'm sure that's
what Milton Friedman or Thomas Sowell
would do
if this is satire it's very well done
um if it's not then it's kind of weird
but I think because I can't tell I'll do
it as a presented without comment
John wrote In
John says hi David huge fan of the show
was excited to find for you to find
another right winger to interview this
week with John T Smithy
I think he was I think it was John
Teague as a tool for your viewers to
understand when confronted with the new
IRS hiring goals that 87 000 number
often thrown around is misleading this
is really important because right
Wingers are loving this talking point of
why does Joe Biden need 87 000 more IRS
agents well John explains first of all
it's based on a proposal from May 2021
and not actually relevant to the current
plan number two the IRS expects 55 000
retirees in the next 10 years these new
agents would replace those folks three
the new hiring quota would be over 10
years rather than immediately you know
that does change
the big picture of that IRS hiring
doesn't it John writes I'm a CPA who has
had this discussion multiple times a
week with clients and I've got to tell
you they look really dumb when I turn
this around on them well John I always
appreciate more information and John
does seem to know exactly what he's
talking about I'll keep that in mind
when they pull the IRS talking points
glorious Taco wrote in saying shouldn't
Abbott and DeSantis be arrested for
those immigrant buses David in the past
couple months Abbott and DeSantis have
been sending busloads of illegal
immigrants to various Northeast
democratic-run cities claiming that
illegal immigration needs to be dealt
with now shouldn't these two be arrested
for knowingly transporting illegal
aliens across state lines a federal
crime and what money is being used to
fund these trips if public funds should
that be another federal crime yeah we
talked about this on Monday
NPR has a really good article about the
possible illegality of the DeSantis
migrant Martha's Vineyard stunt I don't
want to rehash everything I said you can
check out that clip but GT you are spot
on in identifying there are a bunch of
possible crimes there a bunch of
possible crimes Anthony wrote in about
Michael Cohen Trump's former lawyer and
says hey David I'm not sure if you
addressed this before but I've been
listening to the Michael Cohen podcast
and I noticed a couple times that he
referenced you as the guy that goes to
Trump rallies and talks to Trump
supporters I don't think he has the
right guy unless you've been out there
in which I'm sorry I even addressed this
I thought maybe he was thinking of
Jordan klepper or some other mockery
type journals yeah so Michael Michael
Cohen's great guy were in touch and he's
a supporter of the show we're going to
have him back on soon I like Michael
Cohen
he sometimes refers to me as a comedian
which I'm glad to be called although I'm
about to show you a voice an email that
says I'm not funny but to the extent
that Michael Coleman finds me funny I'm
glad for him to call me a comedian
Michael Cohen has also said the guy that
goes to Trump rallies and when Michael
Cohen interviewed legal analyst Asha
rangappa Asha also said I'm the guy that
goes to the Trump rallies so we've sent
people to Trump rallies we will also
sometimes look at clips from Trump
rallies I don't know where it all came
from your guess is as good as mine
um but I know exactly what you're
talking about
humor here is someone who doesn't like
my humor or says I'm not funny
like the show a lot Dave
but find your humor a bit lacking not a
complaint at all but the dim sum word
with bobert cracked me up she's in my
district as Peter's in Mesa County trial
date for Peters that was just set is six
months from now no lack of loons around
here very much appreciate your efforts
uh says Tom you know
does it make sense to say that my humor
is lacking when it's not a comedy show I
don't I don't know I mean it's sort of
like if you said I didn't like uh what's
a really like hard-boiled
TV show it's kind of dark I don't know
there's this there's actually a really
good German uh time travel show called
dark and it is a dark show
it would be weird to say now the humor
is lacking it's not a comedy series so I
just don't know about this my humor is
lacking it's not really meant to be a
comedy show so I don't know let me know
what you think about what Tom has to say
Mike in New York City also wrote In Mike
said David I always found it hilarious
that Maga people think they're being
clever by saying let's go Brandon and
that they think this bothers anyone on
the left at all I think democrats should
Co-op you mean co-opt should co-opt the
phrase let's go Brandon they should
start chanting it in support every time
Biden does something good yeah I that
would be funny you know a lot of times
taking back the phrase is kind of silly
in this case I think it would be funny
for the left to also start using let's
go Brandon as a positive one of the
cringiest things is when these right
Wingers you can you see them and you can
they think they're so smart and clever
and incisive when they go let's go
Brandon and some of them email me
and they'll say David can you tell
Brandon to pay attention to his
teleprompter or whatever you know that
type of thing
and they genuinely think they're being
super clever it's cringy the entire
let's go Brandon thing is one of the
cringiest out there and the funniest
part of it is how clever they think they
are they will never change at least that
doesn't seem like it anytime soon make
sure you were signed up for our bonus
show
oh my clip isn't even plain
that was weird it like came out of the
wrong speaker anyway you know Alex Jones
doesn't like the bonus show just
remember that to me that's a great
endorsement of the bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
and get instant access to that very same
bonus show we've got one coming up today
right after the podcast
thank you